you see the hair on that guy
and there we go
e4 and e6 we repeat the french okay
knight c3 takes on e4 ultra solid but
very passive opening
ooh
i think not
i think somebody called it like the fort
box or something yes it's the fort knox
variation knight d2 was played in the
previous game yeah yeah
you can take on it through with the
knight this is ultra passive for black
ultra ultra passive but solid very solid
you trade away your bad bishop
and you just say i have no weaknesses
come get me exactly and uh save king
also very important
now we've seen
wasn't this from their playoff this is
what they said in their playoffs so
we'll see when they deviate although i'm
sure that fabian was pleased with the
position that he got no doubt
you got the space advantage you have the
pair of bishops but remember there is
no increment until they reach move 61
which is kind of far away
and here he goes 85 off to the races
b5 wow
whoa whoa g6
this already feels
to say that uh
guys they're still following the first
game they're still following the first
they're still following the first game
but it feels like white is built up of
why these crushers are admittable attack
objectively white is crushing right and
he said
one of jeffrey's coach said tell him
that this was terrible what is he doing
what is jeffrey this looks awful right
first impressions are just aren't the
rooks coming yeah a rover yeah but the
second impression is worse
guys we have the same position that we
had in the first game and right now
jeffrey has burned through one minute
and 10 seconds of his time why would you
repeat this so rook g3 okay we see the
first deviation which is b4 but
not exactly an exciting move right that
kind of helpful isn't it i mean i'd
rather have my opponent be seven at them
before
i think i'd rather have my bishop on
f6 than on b2 or c3 yeah this is a plus
three advantage
plus three plus no way i would really
guess that i would have said a plus one
this is a plus three according to
that's kind of sick bishop g7 wait what
happens on bishop g5 here bishop g5 is
like out automatically all right
now we know that
advantage
bishop well bishop f4 also makes sense
just defend the pawn sure but bishop g5
was just begging to be played right for
crazy
is he going to pull out ray robinson
take on a4
thank you for the pawn no but i'm
thinking rook
e1 to d1 right here right now
and then i play bishop g5 no he pulls
out ray robson b takes a4 thank you for
the past pawn good move
knight c5 okay so now is the time to
play rook g3 or h3 or g3 something like
this right right and just go for the
king side attack you have more space so
you don't want to trade pieces including
these rooks i think you just put the
rook on the king side somewhere
anything
must win game four five remember that it
is draw moves jeffrey on rook d6
in the heart of the position
does bishop e5 work no
knight p7 ugly move
c5
c5 we can take it knight b7 and the
exact same setup was played in game one
as well really h66
wow
i'm not so sure about what fabiano is i
think he's okay trading pieces in this
version because he has a passed pawn on
the a file he does but
i would have probably
killed him or yeah
i mean i i do believe white has a much
superior ending don't get me wrong
rookie one queen rook d8 queen d8 queen
uh and this past pawn on the a file uh
could make noise but wow it could also
just be winning right yeah isn't it what
wasn't there just
a devastating kingside attack in there
somewhere i i think that sometimes you
have too many options on how to win a
game and you choose one it might not be
the most convincing but
with the potter on a4 i mean
yeah the pawn on a4 is just such a huge
um
factor and the fact that black is not
trading pieces it just
exemplifies how bad this position is
right by the way this way
oh wait three knight takes uh no a3
knight takes a4 queen takes b4 no no the
bishop
i apologize there is a bishop on avatar
you can't take me upon i cannot take
back with the queen because then we
exchange and the knight on a4 is hanging
right with the bishop maybe queen ah
quindi doesn't work
he was defended so is it queen d1 and
just uh
a4 okay because he had a moment ago an
option of playing queen d2 or queen d1
and i wasn't sure which was better as it
turns out
it might really
so we can get in f4 and defend the e
pawn not with the passive bishop
that's make progress here yeah that's
the question queen d4 what a move what
happens if i take on
queen d7 of course
and that's why jeffrey does hey jeffy
just seems to be so nonchalant
about well everything that's going on
here well that's not a lot of progress
there for favi queen d4 queen d2 the
king is now on e8 it covers covers the
the business yes yes very nice
on d7 if anybody has improved their
position in the last three moves it was
black no question about it and maybe
knight a4 is a real
idea now yeah and jeffrey's playing
although i'm i'm i'm really wondering
right why not just
sorry
what if i take one a4 we'll find out
we certainly will
excuse me is that a pawn and do you have
it well no he just recovered his pawn
yeah but do you have any advantage left
is the question exactly well it's trying
to make them
i'm not sure how
what if i just take this bishop and then
go back
to c5 yeah well can i worm in with queen
f6 and that's the question right also
now that i see i don't think there's a
lot of options because bishop b7 is a
huge threat queen d6 following up and c6
would be hanging in check and everything
hangs with guys
i think you have to play it i think you
have to play bishop g5 queen g5 move the
knight back and close your eyes
he's doing it
move the knight back or move the knight
forward forward boom into the position i
don't think it has a threat
queen f6 queen f6 just eyeballing a you
take on h there's no increment and
there's 45 seconds left for jeffrey oh
we're about to see pieces fly
pieces are about to fly
queen h a check and queen takes h7 takes
a lot of time and there will be a
counter play against the uh the so you
started 94 maybe 94.
you're and what he's worse
is he yes he's lost
he's losing this is just great for
uh but he has jeff
is still good but he has a huge time
advantage
and look at that
oh wait wait wait what a move by jeffrey
queen d6 that is nice oh he's winning
now completely winning wait why is he
winning he's forcing the trade of the
queens no no he's not first of all i
have a bishop d5 but even in that end
game is it actually winning all right
you can take on d6 and then bishop to e8
or bishop to b5 and then wait and then
go to b and then flagger
but i could also just move the queen
right like something like queen c 2 24
moves and writes
24 minutes after queen takes guys this
is move 44. it's extra points oh it's
not only 16 moves and
look at fabby's clock you're not gonna
fight oh really
really eight but you have to speed up
you have to speed up as jeffrey and
jeffrey has got this version is terrible
knight c3 knight a2
definitely this is the worst version
because even king c5 and you get knight
d6 defending f7 oh that's this is oh
what a turnaround jeffrey's taking this
one and who has more time who has more
time on the clock it's jeffree show he's
taking this one yes that is incredible
wow
he certainly is knight d6 you have to
make a five right hand f6 f6
oh
i'm not sure about that one oh he had
knight f7 check
and
definitely looking for his chance with
bishop g6 you have to play a move
knight f2 oh bishop g6
you have to play a move bishop f5 draw
perhaps
not so easy
he has to make it though flagged he
flushed no way who flagged jeffrey flop
60.
[Music]
one more and he didn't and he would have
got his increment and there's fabby did
you see that look of relief
papi went
wait but jeffrey's wondering
why didn't he get a two second increment
he made
move 60.
uh
but we hadn't we the thing is i was told
it was move 60 where the increments
started 61. and then we saw a graphic
with the 61. with the 61. and i never
thought this would be an issue of course
not but
could it be that
naturally on move 61 he didn't get an
increment and maybe he felt he should
have been deserving no wait a minute
but why was he playing so fast so he
just played
his last move as black
was move 60.
king g2
he did not play he did not finalize see
he doesn't get those two seconds right
king c3 is move 60 let's see if he makes
it before his time expires so knight f5
check the king that's right one second
that's why and then it's no no he hasn't
dates here no not even close not even
close
he did not make move 60 by clock no
not at all it did not no because yeah
yeah because king c3 was moved 60.
wow wow
wow
okay
uh guess who just became a great fan of
this format
that was entertaining
in slow motion too great stuff
wow
wow i'm sure sean
did you see abby's reaction too fabby
was like
move 60 move 60.
two seconds increments
if he gets to play king c3 knight d4
what was he playing so slowly i don't
understand that oh my god he was just
like so relaxed
moving the pieces on the board
blast those moves on the board and break
that's that clock fabie was incredibly
lucky because right about here this is
perfect you have three seconds to make
three moves that's this this is an
absolute this should be doable this is
an absolute dream position at this
moment
for black jeffrey this is a lack of
experience you don't you don't move the
knight it's too far from the clock
you know what i mean it's on the other
side you push the pawn yeah you got it
my what
what a finish to this match absolutely
crazy
and i just want to boldly point out the
obvious we were saying that at this
exact moment as we get fabby miked up as
black